we've made enormous progress this year
tackling
the pandemic across britain we're not at
the
end of it but the signs are very hopeful
that progress has been hard won one by
the
speed and success of our nhs vaccination
program
by the huge scale of our testing
and by the sheer sacrifice and the
discipline
of the british public and so it's
important
that we don't put that success and
undermine it now by putting it at risk
getting a vaccination feels like being
given your life back
newly vaccinated thanking the wonderful
volunteers
people in tears of relief but
as well as the joy there's also concern
about resurgence of
kovit and it's a caution we absolutely
share
as a government and it's why the only
route out of this pandemic is
careful and prudent a responsible one
of course we're also as a nation a
group of people who thrive on travel a
nation with
family ties across the globe notably
nearly one in three new mothers in the
uk
was born overseas and in 2019
uk residents took over 93
million trips abroad so i'm glad to be
standing here today announcing the first
albeit
tentative steps towards unlocking
international travel
we want a summer in which with the help
of vaccines and testings
we can reunite family and friends
travel to places we love we want to
start looking
outward again whilst covered has
isolated us travel reunites us even if
video calls have kept us all connected
during the
very long lockdowns there's simply no
substitute
for human contact travel is of course
also
absolutely crucial to rebuilding our
economy
bringing long-awaited relief to hard-hit
airlines airports the tourism sector
which taxpayers have spent seven billion
pounds
in supporting but i have to be
absolutely straight with you our success
in
combating covid here with two-thirds of
adults now vaccinated is not yet
replicated in many places abroad
we in this country have managed to
construct a fortress
against covert but the disease is still
prevalent
in other parts of the world most notably
at the moment
in india in fact more new cases of covid
have been diagnosed around the world in
the last seven
days than at any time since this
pandemic
began nobody nobody
wants to go back into lockdown not ever
and that's why today's announcement
removing the stay in the uk restrictions
from
the 17th of may is necessarily
cautious we must make absolutely sure
that the countries we reconnect with are
safe
that their infection rates are low and
that their
vaccination rates are high it means
making sure
that we're not incubating the most
dangerous variants that they're not
and that they have safe and secure
surveillance in place
and that's why the global travel task
force
has come up with the traffic light
system classifying destinations
by risk and this is based on data by the
joint biosecurity center and it will be
published
on gov dot uk red countries
are those which should not be visited
except in the most extreme
of circumstances where repeated testing
and isolation in designated government
hotels on return
is compulsory non-uk residents have been
been in a red country in the last 10
days will still
be barred from entering the uk
i have to tell you now that due to
concern about
covert rates and variants of concern
turkey
the maldives nepal must regrettably
be added to the red list today
amber countries form the biggest group
as with the red list
you should not be traveling to these
places right now returnees will
have to do tests on three separate
occasions once before departure twice
after arrival
and isolate in a place of their choosing
for ten days finally
we have the green countries which you
will have the opportunity to visit no
earlier than the 17th of may
as long as you take a pre-departure test
before returning
to england and a second pcr test two
days
after you return and with these green
countries you will not
need to quarantine and travelers will be
glad to hear that we've been successful
in driving down
the cost of tests however by necessity
this initial green list must be i'm
afraid limited
so i'm announcing today that from may
the 17th you'll be able to travel to 12
green list countries and territories
which includes portugal
gibraltar and israel i regret the
favorite summer destinations like france
and
spain and greece are not yet included
but every three weeks from reopening
we'll be reviewing the countries
to see how and where we can expand the
green list so
this is just a first step the signs
overseas are now more promising as a
result of their vaccination programs
beginning to crank up
and as the summer progresses we hope
that more traditional tourist
destinations
will be unlocked but we have to turn the
key slowly
and greenless countries will be placed
on a watch list
if we start to have any concerns and
if it's necessary because of a new
upswing in cases or
a new variant will not hesitate to act
fast and
withdraw green status
so it's up to you to check thoroughly
before traveling and if you're thinking
of booking a holiday
in a green list destination please check
the restrictions
applying to new arrivals you can get
this information
on gov uk and it is important because
each country has its own restrictions
indeed
our strong advice is not to book any
holiday which does
not include a refund in the event that
the covid
related situation changes and you're
able to cancel
and i'm afraid we do expect longer
delays at airports and
paul will be saying more about this in
just a moment
but all these measures are necessary to
protect us from
new variants and guard against a
resurgence of
infections and that is why the uk has
now developed the most comprehensive
testing regime on the planet testing up
to 2 million people per day
mobilizing our world leading genome
sequencing
to spot mutations that could lead to new
variants and these are if you like the
walls
of our fortress because the first duty
of any government is to preserve the
safety
of its people but it's also our
responsibility to show
global leadership to work with other
countries to create safe standards for
international travel these were the
issues i discussed with the
g7 transport secretaries when i chaired
a meeting
with them earlier this week i was able
to set out
our own traffic light system as part of
international leadership the
government's working to develop these
standards
and global standards for digital travel
certification
so from the 17th of may english
residents will be
able to use their existing nhs
health app to gain access to their
vaccine
records alternatively they'll be able to
request a paper
letter to verify the vaccination status
now before i finish let me make one
final point
i know that there are many people
watching who might want restrictions to
be
lifted faster and to go further and
there are
if anything more people who prefer us to
go at a slower
pace what what unites us all i think is
the belief that
we don't want to return to the days of
misery and suffering and
loss and we must keep our fortress built
at such a
huge cost to all of us secure
until brighter days when unrestricted
travel
will allow us to meet people who mean
the most to us
for now we must tread carefully
respecting
the science that will guide us along the
way